then would you call yourself competitive
I don't have a competitive nature uh but
uh I thinking but I'm competitive with
myself I would say I'm I love challenges
for myself I'm giving myself tons of
challenges all the time and that I think
that's the most fun and that's the great
thing it's not about competing with
other people that is competing with
yourselves and in in elevating the bar
and just trying to reach for for more
and more and for this movie I was
challenging myself to writing writing it
in such an amount of time shooting it in
such an amount of time was shot in 12
days and and the day before the last day
we shot an eight page is seen in two
hours for me I moviemaking is like the
ultimate team sport and it's about
challenging yourself and the other
people who are working with you so when
we shut these eight pages seen in two
hours it felt so good at the end of day
because we had everything we wanted to
have when didn't need anything more and
it was something which we couldn't do
any longer because we had the location
at UCLA for this amount of time and we
knew that we couldn't stay any minute
longer so we had these what people could
see as a pressure for me is it's a limit
but I love limits limits from either way
to get a way around it and make it
happen and and the Sun was going down so
we had only two hours and we made it
happen because everybody on set every
actor every crew was doing their job
they were right in their position and we
just shot and we got it so competition
within yourself yeah where does that
come from
I think that comes from me as a viewer
also i love when I love bravura when
filmmakers just transcend a story and go
beyond beyond intellectual or limits or
go beyond scientifical stuff or go
beyond what filmmaking is beyond just
using a camera as a tool i mean i love
that's why people go and see gravity i
mean when you are you are in gravity you
are in the movie you these long texts
are not something for the sake of doing
long takes it's something which elevates
the story and bring you in the story as
a viewer so I love the challenges as a
way to get better stories and to to get
to get better images to get better words
to throw people into do you have a trait
of getting things done I see that about
you seeing you get things done yeah I
that's a that's my motto that we might
borrow to make it work and to get things
down especially in movie set you have to
you have to get things done otherwise
there nobody is going to help you I mean
as the director that's the role the set
is a chaotic place is very caring place
and it's a dangerous place also e and
that's I think what a lot of people who
have not been in said no no bad movie
said it's a dangerous place and that's a
caring place and as a movie maker I
think our role is to manage chaos and
stew and to keep people focused and to
show the way and to get things done even
though so many weird crazy stuff can
happen in the seta you have to keep I
mean you
you are the commander of a boat you have
to keep going
you